[Musica]
la presentazione grazie a voi che siete
qui per me era oltre che un piacere e
anche un piccolo desiderio realizzato
quello di venire a fare un intervento al
ted e la gioia di farle in questa sala
oggi secondo me accadono almeno tre
miracoli qui il primo miracolo e io alla
benedizione che lo vivo quasi tutti i
giorni perché da iniziamo incontrato
quasi 35mila persone che fanno parte di
quell'italia che di sabato ma fare un
corso fi km equa speaker dopo speaker
prende appunti porta a casa idee e mi
puoi dare un attimo la luce e
quell'italia che io ho visto per decenni
da mio papà quando ero ragazzino mentre
luce in sala per favore
quando ero ragazzino lui faceva
l'imbianchino e faceva i contratti con
una stretta di mano tutto andava
velocemente tutto funzionava perché era
un paese l'italia in cui dominava la
fiducia oggi purtroppo non è così non è
così fra le persone non è così a volte
anche quando ci guardiamo allo specchio
non abbiamo questo livello di fiducia e
per me incontrare mille persone che
invece ci credono io non vi conosco non
conosco personalmente la vostra storia
so che se siete qui a distanza di una
giornata cercare di portare a casa idee
e spunti e perché se un livello di
fiducia superiore a quello che
normalmente incontriamo in giro 2 farlo
a sanpa questo per me è un luogo magico
io da sette anni frequento questo posto
luogo in realtà più che magico forse
proprio mistico perché qua accade il
miracolo della rinascita con le persone
tornano a vivere e in questo auditorium
sette anni abbiamo ospitato un sacco di
persone per cui quando so che c'è il ted
migliaia di persone con una fiducia
superare la norma ed è a sanpa cerco
veramente di dire voglio raccontare la
mia storia in dieci minuti di una bella
sfida perché insomma io ho la fortuna di
fare ore ora in aula come avete visto un
sacco di di colleghi oggi fare questo
genere di attività di lavoro
comprimere tutto in 9 minuti e 55
difficilissimo mi sono messo lì carta e
penna poi a un certo punto buttato via
tutto e ho detto non voglio insegnare
niente voglio solo raccontare come io ho
25 anni fa come tante persone
ho iniziato come ho iniziato perché
forse era e la parola e la la domanda
più frequente che mi viene fatta io
quando incontro alle persone mi dicono
gianluca ho un sacco di idee un sacco di
spunti da dove iniziò come parto come
faccio fare il primo passo
e allora voglio raccontare la storia di
un ragazzo di 19 anni che figlio di un
imbianchino ho detto di una cameriera
con un titolo di studio appena appena
fatto in chimica alimentare viene
chiamato contattato per iniziare una
carriera da venditore nel mondo del
marketing sembrando del 1995 mentre mia
mamma un po pregava che mira vedessi un
po si vergognava perché lei sperava che
io facessi impiegato bancario che
facessi l'avvocato sappiamo che quasi
tutti i genitori vogliono che i figli
realizzano i sogni i desideri che loro
non sono stati in grado di realizzare
insomma io inizio è forse proprio questo
il verbo che vorrei dire con forza oggi
vorrei che fra nove minuti quando già
salutiamo vi rimanesse un concetto di
meno forse un concetto fatto di tre
parole uno di questi è il potere
nell'iniziare di iniziare perché noi
vogliamo realizzare vogliamo portare a
casa compiti progetti ma la verità che
tutto parte da un primo passo è che se
aspettiamo ogni volta che tutto sia
pronto nulla mai sarà pronto
l'inizio è un insieme di volontà e di
fiducia è un insieme di confida di
confidare di confidenza con quello che
accadrà
insomma questo ragazzo di 19 anni inizia
e nei primi cinque anni fa un sacco di
fatica quando io stavo facendo fatica
prima ho sentito paolo dire una cosa
meravigliosa
ci hanno insegnato prima il sacrificio
anziché
la gratitudine anziché la misericordia è
vero devo anche dire che 25 anni di
sacrificio mi sono stati utili quasi
sempre nella vita noi vogliamo fare
qualcosa ottenere un risultato
proprio su questo palco due anni fa
avevo con me paolo dallara è un
imprenditore oggi di 83 anni che ha
iniziato la sua attività a sua impresa
più di 60 anni fa che mi ha insegnato
una cosa preziosissima ma ha detto
gianluca le fasi della vita sono tre
imparare ottenere e restituire e io
finchè non even incontrato lui non avevo
capito che i miei primi cinque anni si
sono chiamati imparare e lui mi dice
gianluca quasi tutti non hanno voglia di
imparare la maggior parte delle persone
vogliono partire dall ottenere vogliono
faccio questo tengo questo e non si
rendono conto è se state prendendo
appunti questa cosa vorrei che era
scriveste che a volte la vita ci paga in
termini economici
a volte la vita ci paga in termini di
conoscenza di apprendimento io da sempre
immagino che ci sia wallet virtuale per
ognuno di noi quando non otteniamo
risultato economico otteniamo nel wallet
un accredito otteniamo che quel wallet
cresce si amplia si amplifica e ci
permetterà poi di poter ottenere dei
risultati
dopo cinque anni e inizio ottenere dei
dopo altri quattro inizio a restituirne
nel mio mondo nella mia attività
ma poi come accade a tutti ecco la
bellezza di questo luogo
ecco l'insegnamento di questo luogo mi
perdo mi perdo accade a tutti di
perdersi se non ti perdi non ti trovi
noi abbiamo paura di perdersi ma in
realtà la maggior parte di noi solamente
quando si perde si incontra
qui c'è l'immagine di dante io ho letto
la divina commedia quando alle superiori
me l'hanno fatto fare e poi l'ho riletta
da adulto insieme ai promessi sposi roma
dalla provvidenza alle confessioni e
quando leggo i promessi sposi e quando
leggo la divina commedia perdonare
e leggo che dante scrive il suo
capolavoro
perché nel mezzo del cammin della sua
vita si ritrova in una selva oscura la
diritta via era smarrita si perde si
perde dante possiamo perderci anche noi
anche noi possiamo avere un momento in
cui ci smarriamo ed arance ci insegna
che se ti vuoi ritrovare devi trovare
una guida dante si affida virgilio nel
suo cammino dante inizia ad ascoltare e
ad apprendere apri le orecchie apre il
cuore la nostra divina commedia il
nostro capolavoro nella vita non
possiamo scrivere solo ed esclusivamente
se prima ci siamo aperti aprirsi e se
poi ci siamo aperti a parte qualcuno che
ci può tenere per mano aperti a qualcuno
che ci è già passato
ecco il miracolo di farlo insieme di non
essere da soli nella comunità della
comunione
insomma io in quella fase in cui mi
perdo incontro le mie guide ognuno di
noi ha delle guide non lo so se vuoi a
casa da bambino elevati i poster dei
vostri idoli
e se da grandi avete i poster delle
vostre guida dei vostri riferimenti
ognuno di noi nelle varie fasi della
vita qualcuno a cui si ispira oggi io
penso che al ted voi avete avuto una
serie di guide qua magari avete preso
qualcosa da uno piuttosto che da
un'altra quando noi facciamo circolare
le nostre esperienze le esperienze
diventano di tutte
insomma inizia la seconda fase della mia
vita è la seconda fase della mia vita è
una fase divertente perché io a quel
punto inizio a fare cose nuove progetti
nuovi mi apre una serie di cose e la
vita mi dà un insegnamento divertente
perché quando mi perdo incontro un amico
un avvocato perché avevo necessità anche
di sostegno legale da quel punto di
vista ne conoscevo tanti gli avvocati
malavita più fantasia di quanto
immaginiamo
e mi porta da lui
ci conosciamo ci confrontiamo e a
distanza di anni quel rapporto diventa
amicizia diventa fiducia a distanza di
anni
lui vive il suo terremoto aveva la casa
e lo studio proprio dietro il campanile
di finale emilia che nel 2013 in una
notte viene giù e con esso tutti i suoi
progetti e con esso tutti i suoi soldi
tutto quello che aveva costruito di
solido professionalmente momento
difficile suo io l'incontro nel momento
di difficile mio e lui mi tiene per mano
e poi lui nel momento in cui si perde
mi chiama ricerca suo figlio viene a
fare un corso con me suo figlio di 24
anni e viene un'idea quell idea la
mettiamo su carta la mettiamo sul tavolo
la facciamo diventare un progetto alla
facciamo diventare un'azienda e a
distanza di due anni con l'azienda oggi
ha fatto decine di milioni di euro di
fatturato
ma non solo per raccontarvi come il
progetto imprenditoriale si sia
realizzato sono qui a raccontarvi che
quel progetto imprese reale sia basato
su una parola importantissima che si
chiama fiducia la stessa che vi ha
portato voi può oggi la stessa perché
voi non conoscevate bene quello che
sarebbe accaduto però avevate fiducia
che sarebbe stata una giornata utile la
stessa che ha portato i ragazzi nella
affidarsi ad una comunità per ritrovarsi
per ritrovare la strada la stessa di cui
hai bisogno oggi fuori un giro nel
nostro paese perché se noi ci guardiamo
ci incontriamo voi trovate occhi persi
in giro il problema che noi stiamo
vivendo non è il pin stagnante e che
abbiamo perso la fiducia
la speranza i nostri nonni non avevano
niente e loro non gli occhi che
brillavano noi oggi viviamo in un paese
che ha pressoché tutto si può sempre
migliorare però ma abbiamo perso la
speranza abbiamo perso la fiducia per
cui se qualcuno mi dicesse gianluca ma
la tua ricetta per iniziare qual è la
mia ricetta abbastanza semplice
io ogni volta succede quotidianamente
che mi arrivano idee e progetti mi
dicono gianluca me la finanzi ci dai una
mano
facciamo qualcosa insieme
per me è prima di tutto ci sono le
persone prima le persone poi progetti
prima le persone poi le aziende se ci
sono le persone arrivano anche le
competenze di banca la crescita e poi
ovviamente c'è l'azione c'è il fare e
questa parola magica questa accendino
questa miccia noi possiamo avere i
fuochi d'artificio più belli del mondo
che ci permettono di illuminare il cielo
di rendere la nostra vita un capolavoro
ma serve sempre comunque una micia serve
sempre comunque un fuoco che accenda
allora mi vien da pensare che questo
fuoco oggi qua potrebbe essere preso da
mille persone che con la loro candela
illuminata vanno in giro vanno fuori
dove le candele non sono illuminate e
scoprono la magia di accendere un altra
candela con la loro e ogni volta che ti
accendi un altra candela ti rendi conto
che la tua non si è spenta la tua non ha
perso niente e comunque la ne ha chiuso
un'altra che ne può accendere un altra
che ne può accendere un altro ancora so
che siamo cresciuti con un concetto
democratico che il 51 per cento delle
persone quella che decide ma ho toccato
con mano che non è così
quando un gruppo di persone anche
ristretto anche solo mille anche solo
100 anche solo 10 crede veramente in
qualcosa ha fiducia e inizia a cadere i
miracoli grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]